les images ont été diffusées par l'armée
russe des colonnes de chars et de
véhicules blindés Ukrainiens semblent
avancer vers les positions russes dans
la région de zaporigia avant d'être
bombardé l'état-major affirme avoir
stoppé 1500 hommes et 150 ans que
craignant
l'ennemi a été détecté très tôt par les
services de renseignement militaire des
forces spéciales de reconnaissance
aérienne qui lui ont infligé une défaite
cuisante
si les affirmations russes sont
difficiles à vérifier certains voient
dans ses combats le début de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne annonçait
depuis plusieurs mois c'est le cas
notamment du journal américain The
Washington Post d'autres médias restent
plus prudents mais font aussi état de
nombreux mouvements de troupes dans le
sud de l'Ukraine c'est de son côté
l'armée ukrainienne déclare se
rapprocher de la ville de bammouth
jusqu'à présent Kief a refusé de
confirmer le lancement de sa grande
offensive elle n'a pas commencé nos
militaires décideront quand elles
commencera en fonction de la situation
sur le front quand la contre-offensive
commencera tout le monde le saura
depuis plusieurs mois qui êtes
l'esplaner le mystère sur le lieu et le
moment mais affirme préparer une grande
contre-attaque contre la Russie et à
même évoqué la Crimée comme cible le
territoire a été annexé par Moscou il y
a 9 ans